battlefield victories
brutality and the bogus promise of
utopia
in a self-declared caliphate
islamic state shocked the world when it
seized swathes of iraq and syria
in 2014 but it also
surged across the gray zone of the
internet winning recruits
and spreading terror in their first
joint interview
the head of gchq and a top general
reveal
new details about how the uk used
cyberspace to fight back against the
group also known as daesh
we piloted some really early
technologies
to uh disrupt daesh's use of some pretty
basic drone technology but which was
causing us
uh a problem is that like is that sort
of code for you you use some kind of
cyber element
to disrupt the drones yes you reached a
red line there obviously and
you know we decided cyber techniques to
affect how a drone operated
a visible military campaign against
islamic state
was mixed with the more covert one with
cyber spies
targeting the group's ability to use
phones and other devices to communicate
so we wanted to ensure that when they
tried to coordinate attacks on our
forces their devices didn't work
but they couldn't trust the orders that
were coming to them from their seniors
they either couldn't trust the messages
that were coming to them
or they weren't working the uk also
hunted islamic state
online targeting slickly produced videos
and other posts we prevented
their propaganda you know both through
physical
actions on the battlefield but also
remotely getting
to their servers getting to the places
that they stored their material
much of this was done from gchq's
headquarters in cheltenham
locking islamic state out of their own
accounts
and deleting or distorting files
the goal was to stop the terrorist
group's media wing from being able to
influence people here on the streets of
the uk
and around the world with news stories
and videos
glorifying acts of violence and social
media posts
aimed at enticing them to join the fight
while islamic state's ideology still
remains
much of its extremist material has been
taken offline
the power of cyber to impact people is
one reason
why the uk has set up a whole new cyber
force
their work is top secret and the threats
are vast
in some respects the most important the
most relevant use of cyberspace
is that the real power is in influence
and not in sabotage
and so what you're seeing are our
adversaries our rivals
exploiting the tools that are meant to
make for a more utopian society so
things like social media
against us fueling conspiracy theories
and really sowing
division and tearing the fabric of
society apart and
you could go so far and describe it as
almost fueling a civil war inside some
of these societies
codes and keyboards the new front line
debra haynes sky news